when I was looking at the difference
between the communist system and the
Western capitalist system I started to
get underneath the belief systems to
find out what was there it UN was
extremely helpful and other thinkers
that I'm sure you've heard me mention if
you've listened to my lectures Nietzsche
and and Dostoevsky and social Nets and
seem to be the people who had dug
deepest down into those subterranean
levels and what I found I think was that
the communist system was very was very
shallow it was predicated on a set of
rational assumptions that were generated
by a handful of people with no real
biological or historical routing and I
think that the fact that that was the
case was part of the reason why when
those ideas unfolded in real time they
were so murderous they just weren't
imagine that you know Karl Marx was
thinking well here's the game that we're
playing and here are the rules and so
that he laid out the rules explicitly
and then people made societies that
follow those rules and it turned out
that that game didn't work at all
he just got it wrong and like seriously
wrong whereas in the West the ideas
emerged from a an unbroken historical
process that stretches back probably to
the beginning of civilization say maybe
maybe all the way back to Africa who
knows how how ancient these ideas are
and there's there's an unbroken
continuity of ideas that emerged up and
that and they're expressed in symbolic
form and it's on that symbolic platform
which actually matches our biology and
our behavior that our more articulated
ideas rest upon and so I found that
extremely useful and surprising I mean
it wasn't what I expected and and at the
same time I was I was I had another
problem that he emerged while I was
dealing with this and one was that I
come to understand what group identity
meant to people like you have to have a
group identity because you live with
other people and unless you have a
shared identity Jonathan talked about
this a bit unless you have a central
pole around which you're all oriented
it's all chaotic and confused and and
you're in constant conflict and warfare
it's like that's a bad thing you don't
you do not want that
and you're all confused individually and
all of that that's a state of chaos it's
unbearable but if you tighten up the
group identity to too great a degree say
like the Nazis tried to do then the
probability that you'll come to blows
with other groups reaches a almost a
point of certainty right and so it
seemed to me that human beings were
damned if they did and damned if they
didn't on the on the one hand if you
dropped your group identity then you
fragmented and degenerated into the
chaos and if you gripped hard to your
group identity then you you tilted
towards totalitarianism and group
conflict and then I thought well that
was okay in the past to tilt towards
group conflict because you know when we
had sticks and swords we'd have a war
and lots of people would get killed and
lots of people would get hurt but the
entire planet wouldn't burst into flames
right so you know this this this inborn
dichotomy of catastrophe that
characterized human existence wasn't
something that could spiral into
complete destruction and so we could get
away with it but now in a thermonuclear
age it's like we didn't we can't get
away with it but that's still what we're
like we're still like that
and so for months I thought oh my god I
always believed that if you could get to
the bottom of a problem you could solve
it because that was sort of the
definition of getting to the bottom of
it you know you a solution would emerge
and when I got to the bottom of it as
far as I could go I thought oh it's
group identity and like group foster
warfare and catastrophe on the one hand
and degenerate nihilism on the other
it's like well jigs up there's no way
out of that and I had a prophetic dream
at that point which and I won't tell you
the details of that but it outlined a
third path to me that that I had already
picked up to some degree from reading
Jung and also Erik Norman who is one of
Jung's great students and that was that
had to do with the embodiment of the
idea of the hero and the individual as
the like the pathway of the courageous
individual as the mediating force
between the chaos of nihilism and the
totalitarian of totalitarianism of
authority and authoritarian certainty
that there was a third path and then I
started to understand its relationship
to
just thinking mostly to Christianity
partly because that's my tradition you
know insofar as I'm a Western person say
and I understood as well that it had
something to do and that this was what
it was dramatized in the in the in the
in the passion story in the New
Testament was that it had something to
do with taking responsibility for
malevolence because Christ is our
cotillion who takes the world's sins
upon himself and what that means in some
sense is that if you read about history
you read about Nazi Germany you read
about the Soviet gulags you don't read
as a observer looking at what other
people have done you read as the subject
and the object of the history you're
both the person who was persecuted and
the victimizer at the same time and you
have to see both of those inside you as
actual forces in order to understand
history properly and of course that's a
very very terrifying thing to do it's
easier to take the part of victim in
some sense even though that's terrible
right because who wants to be the victim
of a concentration camp obviously but
maybe that's preferable ethically to
being the perpetrator but when you're
reading about Auschwitz you're not
reading about past history you're
reading about exactly what people are
like and that's a very terrifying thing
and so one of the things you have to do
if you're going to take responsibility
for the nature of your being is to take
responsibility for the malevolence
that's truly part of human nature and
that's that's part of the encounter with
the shadow from the Union perspective
and you know one of Ewing's proposition
was that the human shadow reaches all
the way down to hell and you know we're
used to thinking of religious language
maybe even as outdated superstition but
if you take that sort of statement
seriously from a psychological
perspective what it means in some sense
is that the malevolence that resides
inside you at least in potential is of
the same sort as the malevolence that
produces the worst things that human
beings is that have ever done